giving summer in balance Middleton step
back
yes
now off the basketball before the red
light comes on
[Applause]
yes he did I told you it was good Wow
whoa all right here we go
smart looking looking for Tatum gets it
in Tatum take C
[Applause]
a lot of fun no question look at this
shot I mean no space to work the game in
three you want to to very stay attached
to Danny here is Bradley James James
going to the rim kicks to the corner
green a three to tie it
[Applause]
and Danny Green is a guy that has made
big shots in the NBA Finals that scream
from Dwight let's see who they're gonna
try to break free is bought down a [ __ ]
[Applause]
chuckle borrow bar as the horn sounds
the jazz win it
[Applause]
rode the initiative man
that's Cody March will trigger the
inbound
[Applause]
oh yeah oh absolutely yeah oh this one
in the win column
Kobe white Saturn ski they won't go away
always in the lamp view mirror
[Applause]
Horton's try and get it and it's ripped
away and zach lavine
as he's done wall
so Adams launches it
[Applause]
all the time and NVA folks and you just
say ok let's just try it
the success rate very low but you got to
try it anyway and clearly
[Applause]
to the basket
[Applause]
little comport turning on the Jets of
the 3-1
[Applause]
Southwest boy he went by buddy he'll
like you were standing in mud and that's
what Westbrook brings to the Rockets
they're not the whole right side for
Derrick Rose Derrick Rose against
through a holiday and he's got some
little mid-range that's it it's over
Detroit Pistons win it and got what they
wanted at the end of the game it's point
if you run another one at him he's too
late to make pass that's that's a heck
of a move yeah yeah I got a lot of space
against a very good defender
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
again
[Applause]
got it off to get to the same winners
for be elites up on their feet here at
the Capitol One Arena Burton's to be a
five-second spiel crossover in the paint
step back for the win Texas second
remaining
credit the Bulls doing a good job not
letting Brad get it from the first round
a great job by Brad on the step-back
[Applause]
is JJ reddick killed him to silence the
crowd 1.1 no timeouts left it meant as a
jarring screen by Derrick Favors Oh
clean it'll be Ingram pop against O'Neal
they'll get it to Brandon Brandon with
two on the clock for the win
[Applause]
the way they do so again guard that
pick-and-roll Brandon Ingram understands
you can forego it so Naomi the inbound
you got to think it's going to be bill
or Burton's to get the shot and moving
fast towards the room all you eat is a
to always a brown jr. finding take the
lead there is still time on the clock
1.6 left to play Ingalls trying to get
it in having trouble
[Applause]
double-teamed on that shot
harden came over get a good job PJ was
all over them the Jazz been six they
cannot inbounds the ball just well the
timeout holds open Tatum hit the rim on
the miss intentionally loose ball
Brown for the tie
[Applause]
in the final quarter now you see how
hardness that rebound see that's the guy
who was supposed to cut off the shock
[Applause]
count and the Hornets were hoping could
they heard the Hornet that maybe it was
a shot clock violation but it was
clearly